if no dentist wears gloves and they're
coming at you with a drill run my name
is Theresa Ellis car I'm dr. Jennifer
Reyes I'm dr. Lu sensei and I will be
rating films about dentistry I would
assume that there's probably be like an
exaggerated truth to what I see
let's get to it Madrid EMA clamp
installed yep
who's using a headstrong plan actually
that's really true we do use Hedstrom
files for root canal it's a special type
of file that helps us to get things out
of the canal we don't just poke the file
though usually it's all the way down
into the tooth in order to get all of
the nerve and blood vessels and bacteria
out of the tooth only thing that is
inaccurate is that they do look like the
patient is able to rinse you didn't have
a rubber dam and a clamp on but that is
something that you would definitely do
for every canal and usually dentists
don't keep their window open wide enough
where a pelican can fly in I say fine an
emu fairly accurate we don't put the
syringe up like this which we usually
try to keep it out of vision we usually
use some topical gel before we even use
anesthesia just to kind of alleviate
some of that pain I just wanted to say
there's a lot of good friends ability in
this town is hey you have some things
you just like diamond coated that's like
really hard so that kitten is moving
like 100,000 revolutions per minute so
it absolutely can pierce through your
nail that is one reason why you
shouldn't move because if this can do
that to someone's finger it can cut your
face it can cut your cheek or your
tongue 3 billboards outside every
Missouri I curate that yes the dental
control can be very very harmful what's
in accurate is that the dentist didn't
wash his hands he wasn't gloved just the
way that he was holding the handpiece
was also incorrect
[Music]
most equipment does not look like that
that looked like piercing tattoo stuff
he has like brass knuckles sometimes
they do go back to some of the older
instruments that were used early 1900s
but it still really doesn't look like
that I don't even know what he's trying
to do he looks like he's trying to take
out a tooth and then now he's drilling
and we don't we're cooking aprons so
much is wrong here Little Shop of
Horrors oh no nothing is true there are
you grinder do you find your teeth i
guide online laughing gasps most of the
time it doesn't make you laugh like this
actually more relaxed most of times
patients are not talking while they're
getting laughing gasps no we're gonna
turn it down she's asking to turn the
gas up and I I think that's screw laughs
who doesn't want to be more relaxed when
they have a dentist's office this is 40
half-true the whole setup and the way
everything looked he was actually
wearing gloves but in terms of
hysterically laughing I have an
experience that it's gonna have to be
shelled I always have final destination
moments though when I'm at the office
if someone doesn't sit on the seat
properly I usually try not to show the
patient the needle before I inject them
because the needles like this long and
scary
and usually if we're drilling and we
notice that a patient is kind of wincing
their face or a teardrop is coming down
that's our indication that you know the
patients in pain were and stop say are
you feeling this are you in any
discomfort or pain there's like some
smoke that's coming up that's really not
accurate especially if there's water
running usually that will help to cool
everything down and the oxygen tank is
running out oh my gosh okay no that
doesn't happen we definitely monitor it
usually there's a dental assistant in
the room that's monitoring the nitrous
and the oxide levels the patient is just
getting just nitrous right now that is
not good that can cause you to come
folds you could vomit you can literally
die Oh
for final destination - none of that is
true it's just way way way too out of
pocket it's just dramatic so hopefully
this helps you out for the next time you
go to a movie and see a dentist office
half of its not true
[Music]
you